♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
CHINESE CORONAVIRUS IS LOOKING
LIKE A REAL THREAT THAT COULD BE
A GLOBAL EPIDEMIC OR MAYBE EVEN
PANDEMIC.
IT’S POSSIBLE.
IT’S THE KIND OF THING THEY
COULD BE VERY SERIOUS.
THOUSANDS OF CASES ALREADY
CONFIRMED, MORE THAN 100 ARE
DEAD.
WITH A TWO-WEEK INCUBATION.
MEH, MORE CASES ARE A CERTAINTY.
SO FAR TRAVELED BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND CHINA IS
COMPLETELY UNAFFECTED.
WHY?
WHO KNOWS, BUT IT IS.
ELIZABETH WARREN’S CAMPAIGN HAS
PUT OUT A CAMPAIGN FOR FINDING
CORONAVIRUS AND OTHER POTENTIAL
PANDEMICS.
ONE ITEM IS FIGHTING GLOBAL
WARMING.
HUH?
OF COURSE.
ONE OF THE TOP CAUSES OF THE
DISEASE IS APPARENTLY RACISM.
RIGHT, OKAY.
THIS IS NOT SCIENCE.
OBVIOUSLY.
IT’S RELIGION.
WHATEVER.
IN THAT SPIRIT, WARREN’S PLAN
CALLS FOR BUILDING EQUITY